Imagine if we could go back in time.
Imagine if we could see what our ocean looked like
in a world with less human impact.
Marine Protected Areas offer us a glimpse of this dream.
Only 5,000 in number,
they are the nature reserves of the sea.
Countries have agreed that 10% of marine and coastal areas must be protected by 2020.
But today only 1 in 10 countries protect more than 2% of their marine areas.
Marine Protected Areas, like nature reserves on land,
nurture recovery and bring new economic opportunities.
Yet, most existing marine parks and reserves are vastly under-funded.
Without effective stewardship, surveillance and accountability,
marine protected areas fail to provide the safe sanctuaries they promise to deliver.
The risks run higher in developing countries and traditional coastal communities,
where inhabitants stand to lose the marine resources they depend on.
How can we, together, ensure that 10% of our ocean will be efficiently protected by 2020?